from where MLB network's Bob Costas
calls into the Rich Eisen show how are
you Bob hey how are you I'm doing fine I
will just lay it all out for you right
here the perspective on the Washington
Nationals run for you would be what well
when you get to October and when a team
is good enough to obtain the playoffs
regardless of what the odds are or the
percentages are any team has a
reasonably good chance of beating any at
the team in a single game if it's the
wild-card for a best-of-five or a
best-of-seven there's a kind of
randomness to October or roll the dice
aspect and by the time the Nats got to
October not only were they playing very
well they won 18 of 20 before they lost
the free straight over the weekend to
Houston but they had the best record in
baseball from their low point on from
the point that they got to 19 and 31 and
late hey they had the best record in
baseball so this was a different team
that began the series against the Astros
than the team that you look at for
overall record if you look at the
difference between the Astros record and
there's clearly the Astros were the
better team over the course of the
season and in fairness to Houston they
have been baseball's best team even
given the great year that the Red Sox
had and winning the World Series last
year they have been baseball's best team
overall over the last three years but
when you get into October the best team
doesn't always win every series you've
got to run that three level gauntlet
through the division series the LCS and
then the World Series and they get to
the seventh game and I've got a two
nothing lead late in the game and then
it slips away and the Nats showed an
ability not only to come back from that
19 and 31 low point but when they got
into the postseason they faced five
elimination games and trailed at some
point in all of them and came back to
win all those games had they lost the
wild-card game to the Brewers which they
very nearly did the narrative would have
been another typical mad season good
enough to make the postseason quick exit
even if they lost the division series
though the Dodgers would have been
favored and the fifth game was in LA
even if they lost that same narrative
get past the Division Series that's how
close they came to having that narrative
hung around their neck and now they're
wasting the championship trophy well
that's the let's zero in granular level
to game seven as you pointed out that
the Astros were up to nothing Greinke
was sitting in a rocking chair I mean he
was having the start of his life and now
he's eight outs away he gives up a home
run to Rend own and then a walk
subsequent to that and out comes AJ
Hinch and I know that this is the way
the world goes in baseball these days
despite having 80 pitches despite how
dominant you have been just a couple of
batters is all it takes for a hook to
bring in somebody who can throw ninety a
hundred miles an hour do you think that
was the proper maneuver last night Bob
in hindsight you can't say that it was
and Greg he had only thrown 80 pitches
he made the one mistake he left one out
over the plate to Rendon and Rendon
launched it and where it not for
Strasburg rendang would certainly have
been the most valuable player had an
incredible world series for the Nats so
now it's 2 to 1 and you're gonna pitch
carefully to Soto so walking him doesn't
necessarily mean that you're losing it
but what enters into AJ Hinch is
thinking is that will Harris has been
just great for the Astros through the
regular season and into the postseason
if there was any sign of weakness it was
that he was used heavily and he had
given up a home run to Rend own in Game
six
but that wasn't reason enough in his
mind to go away from him and a lot of
people watching the game including
ballplayers and longtime observers said
where's Gerrit Cole and AJ Hinch each
thought was Cole has never pitched out
of the bullpen his entire professional
career so if he was going to use him he
was going to use him at the start of an
inning clean inning rather than bring
him in cold or with someone on base so
he goes to will Harris and the ball at
Howie Kendrick hit sliced down the
right-field line plunks over the foul
pole onto the foul pole just over 320
feet you know it's a home run for sure
does it mean that Harris was tattoo not
necessarily but there goes the lead
and it's just a few pitches Cranky's
cruising up to nothing and in the blink
of an eye they're down 3-2 now where you
could question
Hinch after that is okay to try and keep
it close you've got the guy who's been
the best pitcher on the planet over the
course of the season to keep it close
even though you're down 3-2 why not
bring in Cole in the eighth I think
that's the larger question for Hinch who
no matter what happened in Game seven
it's still one of baseball's best
managers and he is there's no doubt
about it I mean the guy is an amazing
button pusher not just not just
strategically during a game but also
just in clubhouses and what to do and
how to handle situations from hurricanes
to you name it the guy has just been
terrific I guess it's just maybe
lamenting the way that the game is
managed
overall and generally that somebody
who's cruising a song Award winner like
Greggy
80 pitches in it's like home run and a
walk that as you point out was a maybe
strategic in its own right also I might
add
aided by what looked like a ball three
that was a strike in the box on the
screen that I'm sure umpires hate so
much it's just I guess I'm lamenting
that that Greinke can't be left in the
game to work it out himself Bob yeah
there's something to be said for that
and as you said the walk DeSoto was not
a case of wildness you're working
carefully Greinke had command the whole
time he's working the corners maybe he
gets that call and it changes that at
that the other part of the thinking is
the dreaded third time through the
lineup so he was hitting that third
times in the lineup but to your point
he's only thrown 80 pitches and all but
one of them had been pretty much what he
intended just the one he left out over
the plate to random in hindsight there's
no denying that he should have been left
there over the course of a season and
all the thought that goes into it you
can defend what interested Bob Costas
here in the Rich Eisen show I would run
through all of his career credits but he
has a plane to catch so I have a few
minutes left with Bob here I'm on the
Rich Eisen show how does Strasbourg's
postseason rank for you based on those
that you have personally eye balled over
the years Bob
oh it was tremendous five and Oh in the
postseason microscopic er a rising to
important occasions he had to keep them
alive in Game six and not only did he do
that but he saved their bullpen
he went deep into the game worked into
the ninth inning pardon me there were a
lot of performances in this postseason
it's going back to what we were talking
about a moment ago a lot of performances
by starting pitchers in this postseason
that made you think maybe this whole
idea give me just five maybe six innings
and then a parade of relievers isn't
always the answer if you've got the
horses in your rotation so Strasburg was
a good choice for MVP as I said Rendon
might have been at Strasburg not been as
dominant as was and in terms of batters
that were clutch I know you're not on
Twitter Bob but I did see this accurate
fact last night on that site that in
Twitter it is it is major upset yes
Anthony Rendon s plate appearances in
the seventh inning or later of the
Nationals five elimination games this
season are as follows walk double home
run double home run double and then last
night's home run this guy was a
revelation certainly in light of the off
season departure of Bryce Harper and the
question is is Rendon's future what do
you think happens here Bob well you look
at the three major names they're not the
only names but the three major names on
these teams that are either three agents
or a Strasbourg's case can opt out and
they all increase their value
there's October Rendon Strasburg and
cold throughout the season and then into
October so they're all in an even better
position than they were a month ago to
your point though when they let Bryce
Harper go and I've said this before and
it's not a knock on Bryce Harper from
the Phillies got their money's worth in
terms of attendance and merchandise
sales and he's a very
very good player but his marquee value
his star presence is greater than his
performance except for his MVP year so
when mike rizzo and the Nats looked at
it they said to themselves if we invest
all the money that it will take to keep
bryce harper then how do we keep red
dome and how do we eventually pay Soto
and Robles and how do we keep Strasburg
if he wants to stay here all that all
those considerations went into letting
Bryce Harper go mike rizzo told me a few
days ago that they will make every
effort to keep both Strasburg which i
think is a pretty good chance that they
will all they have to do is sweeten the
deal he already has it's not going to be
that large an investment and he's a
creature of habit you probably will want
to stay it'll be tougher to keep Ren
don't but Ren don't old me that he's
certainly open to whatever the Knights
have to say it's the only professional
organization he's ever been with it's
kind of good relationship so it's very
possible that they could keep them both
and if they do if they do letting Bryce
Harper go plays into that as far as Cole
if you heard his postgame comments they
had a tone to them that almost made you
believe he was already on his way out he
was kind of speaking in the past tense
this has been a wonderful relationship I
learned a lot about the game from
Verlander and from Brent Strom and from
AJ Hinch it almost had a past tense
feeling to it so all those three if I
had to guess the guy who's most likely
to wear a different uniform next year is
Derrick Cole well in terms of wearing
something different Gerrit Cole was
wearing a Scott Boras logo to hat when
he was delivering those comments last
night Bob so I think that might give you
an indication of where he's thinking
right I mean and by the way just
checking that was not a dollar sign logo
I don't believe it was an actual Boras
logoed sign even though dollars I might
be might be synonymous with that so if I
gave you a sit-down we
Rob Manfred and maybe you do have that
sort of sit down coming over the next
weeks or months what and he says to you
Bob well what what what do you think I
could wave a wand and make one rule
change or I can go into what various
competition committees or ownership
groups and pound the table on behalf of
the commissioner's office looking after
baseball but I could make this table
pound what would you suggest he do that
for well we know what the biggest issue
is and rather than pinpoint a particular
remedy I think the overriding issue is
that what baseball people in the modern
era with justification with analytics
and all the data they have what they
believe is best for giving you a
competitive edge and a chance to win is
not really what's best for entertainment
case of play is the biggest issue and if
you're going to have a parade of
believers and if you're going to have
teams that to their credit go deep into
counts because they're battling on every
pitch they're getting credit for good
cakes is the balls you put in play and
if launch angle is the big new thing and
strikeouts don't matter you're going to
have more strikeouts or more deep counts
with swings and misses you're going to
have fewer balls in play velocity is in
play you're not going to tell somebody
you can't throw 98 miles an hour but
there aren't as many Greg Maddux or Kyle
Hendricks types anymore who pitch to
contact so you get the at-bat over in
fewer pitches I don't know how you
impose upon teams and the people who run
teams impose upon them hey look don't
use an approach that seems to work for
winning because it makes the game less
entertaining or less accessible to fans
who have shorter attention spans but
that's a real a real conundrum for
baseball Bob really appreciate the time
and another great season I guess last
one for you as I send you out the door
what was the moment of the season for
you whether you called it um you know at
the microphone or you witnessed it or
you sat at home watching baseball what
what do you think was the moment of the
season mm and
well I think if you're talking about
just a moment
the Nats winning the championship is the
overriding story but if you're talking
about a single moment it sent them to
the World Series where they fell short
but I would say it was out to Bay's
homer off Chapman to win Game six of the
ALCS and win the pennant to the Astros
and send the Yankees home and in that
one moment you think of Altuve great
call by Joe Buck which is the way most
of the nation received it you think
about that scene and then you picture
Chapman standing on the mound with a
kind of stunned smile on his face
it's what just happened if you're
looking for a moment I think that's the
one moment yeah because it was just a
man because it looked like we were gonna
have a game seven all of a sudden with
another big comeback by the road team
right there man the road teams were just
I've never seen anything like it Bob and
I don't know if it has anything to do
with I guess the leveling of play or
that everybody could throw a hundred
miles an hour or or it's just
happenstance I don't know but it was you
know you know this you know this that
the last several world series including
the last several game sevens have all
ended with the road team winning and
coming into this game last night the
researchers at MLB Network came up with
this and maybe you've heard it by now
but counting the NBA and the NHL with
baseball those are the league that play
best of sevens there have been more than
1400 best of seven series they didn't
although seven games obviously but more
than 1400 best of seven series played in
those three sports and prior to last
night there had never been a series
where the road team won the first six
games let alone all seven day yeah I
know it's unreal and I looked it up
because I was wondering the 2013 Red Sox
as I mentioned the top of the show here
were the last team to celebrate in front
of their home fans to clinch a world
series everybody else has done it on the
road you know and as a matter of fact I
thought that was so germane and also
unique I tweeted it out Bob I put it on
my Twitter feed last night
there you go another worthwhile
termination on Twitter you're beginning
to change my mind
just slowly but surely I should do it
why don't you just curate it for me and
whatever Rich Eisen thinks is okay but
he forwards it to Bob Costas and and I
have a better view of Bob I will I'm on
it I'm on it thanks again for for the
call you're the best and we'll chat soon
that's Bob Costas right here or at Bob
Costas did somebody have that let's look
that up right here on the Rich Eisen
show for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel - 39 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app